For this question you're asked to record the number of clicks for a URL for a given keyword.
So when the URL is chosen for that keyword and the user clicks on it.
Now this is so that we have a measure of the popularity for the URL,
and so the search results can be ordered on that.
In order to do this we're going to have to change the stucture of our index
so that we have the count associated with each URL
and in order to do that we're going to replace the URL with a list which is url, count.
That means that everytime we have the url we have to replace it with a list [url,0]
because the count initally will be 0.
That changes the structure.
What we haven't yet done is taken into consideration the duplicate elements.
We're going to do something similar to the previous question where you were asked to remove duplicates.
from the index but this time it's going to be slightly different because of this structure of url, count.
We're going to check we have the keyword as before
then when we have the keyword,
we're going to loop through this list here
and we're going to check whether each element in the list here,
whether the first position in that is our URL.
If it is, then we're done - we don't want to add it again to the index.
If it isn't there, after we've looped through all of the URLs
then we'll add it to the index as before.
That takes care of duplicates
and the change in the structure of the index
what we now need to do is to sort out the clicks.
To do this, we're going to look up in the index to find our keyword
and that's going to give us all the associated urls.
If we've got some urls
- well if we haven't got any urls, then there is nothing to do
we're not going to be able to click on anything.
If we have got some urls if the first position is our url that we're looking for -
remember than lookup now return this whole list of url, count pairs
so we're just going to have to look at the url, the first entry to see if it matches to see if it matches
rather than the whole list
and so if it does match
then we're going to increment the count, which is the second position by one
and that's it.